SPEAKER 1: Good
morning, everyone,
and welcome to this
talk about color.
So, how many of you think
they understand color?
Raise your hand.
Nobody?
OK, I guess that's
why you're here.
So I gave a similar talk
last year at AnDev 360,
and there was a lot of math
and a lot of equations,
and a lot of worried
developers asked me
if there's going to be
math in this presentation.
There's going to be
no math, no equations.
Instead, there's
going to be physics.
So let's talk about color.
The first question we
have to ask ourselves
is, what is color?
It sounds like a deep question.
The answer is not so deep.
So here's a definition
that applies to most of us
as human beings.
We're not developers,
we're just regular people.
So, it's a visual
perception that
can be described by hue,
brightness and colorfulness.
Sometimes colorfulness is
also called saturation.
And if you've ever
used the HLS, HSL, HSB
colors in Android
APIs, you may be
familiar with that
kind of definition.
What's really
important to understand
is that color is just a
perception of our brain.
It's not a real thing, and
we're going to see why that is.
So obviously, we see colors
with our eyes, and if any of you
see color through another means,
I would love to talk to you.
And to understand how
we perceive color,
we first have to
go back probably
to high school or college
and try to understand
what light is made of.
So I'm sure most of you know
that light is made of photons,
but there's a duality to light.
It can be a wave or particle.
And we're going to look at the
wave nature of light first.
So light is an
electromagnetic wave.
And our eyes are
just receptors for
these electromagnetic waves.
So, here's the
electromagnetic spectrum.
It's not to scale.
And from the shortest
wavelengths to the left
to the longest
wavelengths to the right,
we have, in order, the
gamma rays, the x-rays,
the ultra-violets, the visible
spectrum, the tiny little bits
in the middle full
of colors, then
we have the infrared, the
microwaves, and then the radio
waves.
The part that interests us is
the tiny bit in the middle,
It's what we call
the visible spectrum.
It goes from about 400
nanometers to 700 nanometers.
And all of us, these
are the only wavelengths
that we can see.
Why does this matter?
Our eyes, like I
said, our receptors,
they are actually made of
millions of small receptors
called cones.
Most of us, almost
everybody has three types
of cones that can
detect different parts
of the spectrum.
So you see the spectrum
here at the bottom,
it has all the wavelengths
of colors that we can see.
And this diagram shows,
in three different colors,
the sensitivity of each type of
cone that we have in our eyes.
They are called short,
medium, and long.
Sometimes they are called
blue, green, and red.
It's not technically accurate to
call them red, green, and blue,
so instead we're going to call
them short, medium, and long.
And they are called that way
because the short ones help
us see in the blue wavelengths,
so ultra-violets, violets,
and blues.
Then we have the
medium ones that help
us see the greenish colors.
And the long ones that help
us see green, orange, yellow,
and a little bit of red.
And you can see there's a lot
of overlap between the medium
and the longer receptors.
So now, what is light?
So light is a distribution
of several wavelengths.
So this is what we call the
spectral power distribution
of a light bulb, so
the kind of light bulbs
that you can find in any house.
It's an orange-ish
light bulb, and you
can see the amount of energy
it outputs in different parts
of the visible spectrum.
You can see here that
this type of light bulb
outputs most of its energy
in the red and orange part
of the spectrum, and that's
why we perceive it that way.
But what happens when the
lights from that light bulb
hits our eyes?
So we saw that we
have those receptors,
the different sensitivities
to different parts
of the spectrum.
So we just multiply
the distribution
of the incoming light
with the sensitivity
of our different cones, and
the result is what we perceive.
So when we multiply
both, we get this.
So when you look at
one of the light bulbs,
you see almost
nothing in the blues,
you see a little bit of green,
and more orange and red,
and then our brain
will interpret
that as an orange color.
The way we actually interpret
the result of this cones
is a little complicated.
And we don't have time to
go into the details here.
You can go look on Wikipedia how
it works if you are interested.
So here's what happens
exactly when we
look at the light source.
There are wavelengths
emitted by the light source.
It hits our eyes,
multiplied by the cones,
and that's what we perceive.
But most of the time, you're not
looking directly at the light.
You're looking at different
objects that surround us.
And how do those objects
get their color from?
So every object also has
what's called a spectral power
distribution.
It's a description
of the wavelengths
that the object can reflect.
We call that the reflectance.
So some of the wavelengths
will be absorbed.
So for instance, a black object
absorbs almost everything
that's incoming, and a white
object will reflect pretty much
all the wavelengths.
So, to perceive the color
of an object, what happens
is we have light come in.
It bounces off an object.
Some of it is
reflected, so we just
multiply the two distributions.
Then it hits our eyes and we
get the final perceived color.
What's very interesting
here is that because it's
a multiplication,
any combination
of light and reflectance can
yield to the same perceived
color in our brain.
So a very simple
example is that, if you
have an orange object
lit by white light,
you're going to see orange, but
if you have a white object led
by an orange light, you're
also going to see the orange.
And our brain does a lot
of post-processing really
to help us understand what is
the color of the light, what
is the color of the object.
And a few years ago, there
was this famous example
of the dress, some people were
seeing it in black and blue,
some people were seeing it
in gold and something else.
And that's exactly what's
happening, is that some of us
were interpreting the
results differently.
And nobody was wrong.
It's just without the context
you can't really know for sure.
So we can swap the
colors, the distribution
of the light source,
and the object,
and we're going to
see the same result.
So that leads us to something
called the Chromaticity
Diagram.
It was standardized in 1931 by
the Commission Internationale
d'Eclairage, CIE.
It's a French
commission, apparently.
And it represents all
the colors that we
can perceive as human beings.
So on that horseshoe
shape, the outside edge
is called the spectral locus.
It represents all
the pure colors,
the pure spectral colors.
So that the spectrum of colors
that we saw in the previews
diagrams actually bands
around that edge all along.
And everything in
between, all the colors
that we can actually
see, are a mix
of all those
different wavelengths.
So it does this weird shape.
It's not a rectangle
or anything.
And there's a lot of colors that
live outside of that spectrum.
We call them the imaginary
colors because we cannot see
them.
No matter how hard
we try, you will not
be able to see those colors.
There are also multiple
optical illusions
that you can find
online that will
help you find those colors.
It's actually really weird--
not everybody can see them
or perceive them.
There's one, for
instance, where it
shows you a blue rectangle
for one of your eyes
and a yellow rectangle
for your other eye,
and the way I see it is this
really weird color that you
can't really describe that keeps
changing from blue to yellow
but never stops on one
of those two colors.
The visible spectrum is actually
a little bit more complicated
than that.
What you're seeing is a
slice, it's a 2D slice.
There's a z-axis that's
coming towards you,
and that is the brightness.
So the footprints at the bottom,
this large footprint you see,
is the dark colors.
It's because our eyes are
better at seeing dark colors
than they are at
seeing light colors.
We've seen what colors are
for us as human beings.
But you know, everybody's
a developer, I think,
in the audience, so the
real question is what
is called for us as developers?
What does it mean
for your application?
So color really is
an [INAUDIBLE] scheme
for brain sensations.
And the formal
definition is that it's
a tuple of numbers,
or a list of numbers,
defined within a color model
and associated with what
we call a color space.
And we're going to
look at some examples
to make you understand that.
So here are some
of the color models
that you may be familiar with.
RGB is one of the obvious ones.
I'm sure everybody
has used that.
CMYK, if you have ever printed a
picture or a book or something,
you might have
also dealt with it.
And there's another one
for instance, called L*a*b.
There are others.
There's xyz.
There's many others.
What's interesting is
that the color model
defines how many numbers
we need to define a color.
So you're used to RGB to
three colors, to three values,
but CMYK requires four
values, for instance.
So the one that we're
interested in today
is the RGB color model.
It uses a triplet of values--
hence the name.
And I'm sure most
of you or all of you
are familiar with the
hexadecimal notation.
So there are many
ways of representing
the tuple of numbers.
This is one of them.
It is pretty popular,
especially on the web.
You have probably used
it a lot on Android
when you want to pass a color
directly to one of APIs.
This is a pinkish color.
So this is the same color
represented as a triplet
of 8-bit [INAUDIBLE] integers.
You are also most
likely familiar with it.
This is something we
use a lot on Android
when you set the
color on the paint
or when you use the
color to try to extract
the red component of a color.
And this is another notation.
This is actually
the one I prefer.
This uses floats.
So the values are
between 0 and 1.
And it's interesting
because it's more versatile.
You can use it to represent
[INAUDIBLE] colors.
And we'll see that
Android actually
makes use now in O
of the float notation
to have negative colors and
colors that go beyond 1.
So the big question is,
once we have those numbers,
what colors do they
actually represent?
So I told you this is a pink.
But you've seen that
spectrum of colors.
There are many,
many, many pinks.
There's actually an
infinity of pink.
So which one of those
pinks does this represent?
So to reproduce colors,
all of our displays
use additive light.
So, we use red, green, and
blue in our TVs, our phones,
our computers, our
old CRT monitors.
And they just mix
those different lights.
So the numbers
that you just saw,
the RGB triplets, it
might sound obvious,
but they're an intensity for
each one of those lights.
So let's say we
pick three lights.
We pick a green light, a
red light, and a blue light.
And they're not perfect
spectral lights,
they're just random
lights that you found.
They are found somewhere
in the visible spectrum.
And together they
form a triangle.
So when you have an RGB
color in your application,
you can only represent
one of the colors
within that triangle.
You cannot represent colors
that live in the entire visible
spectrum.
That triangle is what
we call a color space,
and there's an infinity of them.
Depending on the three
lights you choose,
you can represent any of an
infinity of color spaces.
So here's, for instance,
one of the widest color
spaces we could create.
The problem we have is that
with a triangle with just three
lights, we cannot encompass
all the visible spectrum.
We have to choose
a smaller slice.
So this one in particular
is called the [? IW ?] wide
gamut RGB color space.
There's no device that I know
of that can capture or recreate
this color spectrum,
this color space.
And the problem is
that if we wanted
to create a color space
with RGB that contains all
the visible colors, we'd
have to create lights that
are in the imaginary space.
So lights that we cannot
perceive because we've seen
that our eyes cannot perceive
outside of that horseshoe
shape.
The color spaces are more
complicated than that.
So color space is actually
defined by three components.
The first ones are
called the primaries.
There are three of them.
Then we need a white point.
And then we need something
called transfer functions.
So this might look like
a complicated diagram,
but what I did is I've put the
visible spectrum on the left,
and I've overlaid
three triangles that
represent three common
color spaces that
are used for still images.
So the smallest one you see in
the middle, the blue triangle,
is the one we call sRGB.
I'm sure you've heard
that term before.
sRGB stands for
Standard RGB, and it
was designed in the '90s.
And it kind of matches the
reproduction capabilities
of the CRT monitors
of back then.
And to this day, it's
still used everywhere.
It's pretty much the universal
color space, the only color
space that you can count on.
There are other color spaces.
There is Adobe
RGB, for instance.
It's the orange triangle.
Because it's bigger than
the sRGB color space,
we say that it's a wide color
space or it's a wide-gamut.
So the three vertices of
the triangle, the triangle
is something we call a gamut.
And then there's
something called
ProPhoto RGB that
you can see extends
beyond the visible spectrum.
And this is not a
color space that we
use to actually represent
colors on the screen.
It is what we call a
working color space.
For instance, when I take
a picture with my camera,
my camera is set to Adobe
RGB, so it captures everything
in the color space
that you see on screen.
Then when I import my
photo in Lightroom,
Adobe Lightroom internally
works in ProPhoto RGB.
And it won't be able to recreate
all the colors that it's
working with on
screen, but the idea
is to have as much
precision as possible.
So you can ignore this kind
of color space for your needs
on Android applications.
So I said a color space
has three primaries,
and the primaries really
are the coordinates
of each one of
the three vertices
of a triangle in that
chromaticity diagram,
in the visible spectrum.
So they identify,
when you [INAUDIBLE]
so it's that you want a
color that's red equals 1,
green equals 0, blue
equals 0, it tells you
what red we're talking about.
And if you look here on the
screen, sRGB and Adobe RGB,
when you say red equals 1,
they have the same exact red,
but ProPhoto RGB
has a different red.
So it's two different reds for
us, and then they [INAUDIBLE]
for computers,.
We'll take a look at that.
And then we also
need a white point,
and the white point
is the same idea,
it gives us the coordinates
of white in the color space,
and we'll get back to that.
So I also mentioned
transfer functions.
Transfer functions are a
little bit complicated.
That's where a lot of
math comes into play.
You've probably heard about
them under the name gamma,
so if you heard about
gamma correction,
that's actually
transfer functions.
So I gave a talk last year
about transfer functions.
I don't have time to
talk about them today.
I'm going to show you a
link at the end of the talk.
If you're interested,
you should definitely
go look at that talk.
There's a lot of
things that you should
learn about transfer
functions that
can impact your applications.
So I've been talking
about color spaces.
But why do we care so
much about color spaces?
So the problem is that
every device out there
has a different color space.
So for instance, you can have
a phone that has an LCD screen
and is going to
be close to sRGB,
you have a phone that
has a [INAUDIBLE] screen
and is going to be closer to
P3, to a color space called P3,
or to the Adobe RGB color
space that we just saw,
and something for your
laptop for your computer
or for your TV.
And things get even
worse, because even
if you have two phones,
they're the same model,
they're the same manufacturer,
they're both supposed to be,
let's say P3, there are
variations in the manufacturing
process.
So they won't be
the exact same P3,
so the colors won't be exactly
the same on those two devices.
I'll show you an
example of what happens.
So let's imagine
that we have content
that we created for sRGB, so
it's in the sRGB color space.
We designed it at
home on our computer
that shows us RGB colors.
That's the wide
triangle you see.
And then if we take that content
as is, we don't do anything
to it, and we just show
it on the display that's
Adobe RGB, what
we're going to do
is we're going to just
take those RGB triplets,
those values we had,
and reinterpret them
in a different color space.
So suddenly your green
that you had in this RGB,
like that green equals one, is
going to be a different green.
It's going to look completely
different to your user who's
using an Adobe RGB screen.
So here are concrete examples.
This is a photo I took.
I took it in Adobe RGB.
I processed it in ProPhoto RGB.
I converted it nicely on my
calibrated monitor to sRGB.
This is what it
should look like.
Actually this is not what it
should look like on my laptop.
It's what it should look like,
because those [? trains ?] have
a curved space.
I have no idea what it is,
but it's definitely not sRGB.
And this is really wrong.
But what matters
is the difference
between the next photos.
So let's say that
this is proper sRGB.
This is how I wanted
you to see the picture.
Now if I display
the picture as is
on a different screen
that said this is P3,
it is going to look like this.
If I go back and forth,
you can see there's
a difference in contrast.
Some of the colors are a
little bit more saturated.
So already my photo does not
look like the way intended.
Then if I display it on
the ProPhoto RGB display,
if such a thing existed,
it would look like this.
So supersaturated,
really garish.
I don't know about you, I
really don't like this picture.
And that happens when you
only affect the primaries.
But you can have
similar issues when
you affect the white points.
So the next slide here,
that is the same sRGB photo.
So we kept the primaries,
but I changed the white point
to something that's bluish.
And so in my photo, well,
you know it's underwater,
so it kind of makes
sense to be blue,
but it is not the way I
wanted it to look like.
So again if you take multiple
Android devices, for instance,
and you put them
side by side, chances
are that some screens
will appear yellow to you,
some screens will appear
blue to you or green,
and that's because
of the white point.
We have different white points
across multiple displays.
And once again, the
same model of device
from the same
manufacturer, there
are going to be white
point variations.
So when this happens, we say
that colors are unmanaged.
This is what Android has
been doing since Android 1.0,
and I hate it,
absolutely hate it.
It's horrible.
Your designers will spend
hours and hours slaving away
on their computer,
creating a beautiful UI,
then you test it on a phone
and it's completely different,
and you test it on
another phone and it looks
completely different again.
So you might be
thinking, how can we
have our design look
exactly the way we want?
So the solution is something
called color management.
And it's new to Android O.
So the idea is that every
color that we want to display
needs to be associated
with a color space.
We need to know what was the
original intent of the design,
so we need that information.
Then, through the magic of
a lot of math and matrices--
it's actually more complicated
than just a matrix,
but that's most of it--
we're going to do a controlled
conversion to the destination
color space.
So what we're going to do
is that, when we manufacture
a device, we're going to
use special devices that
will measure the
capabilities of the display.
We're going to measure the
primaries and the white point
of the device, we're going
to create a destination color
space, and then we can
convert your original content
to the destination color space
and preserve the same colors
that you wanted to have.
So this is something we're
introducing in Android O.
And there are two parts of it.
There's first color
management proper,
and then there is something
called the wide color gamut
rendering.
And we're going to
take a look at both.
But first, before you need
to worry about Android,
you need to make sure
that you or your designers
are using color spaces properly
in your design application.
And there are two things
you can do with pictures--
you can assign a color space, or
you can convert a color space.
So I'm going to
switch to a demo,
but first I just
want to show you,
earlier I said that color
spaces, this chromaticity
diagram we had, the
horseshoe shape,
it's a slice of the
color space, and so are
the gamuts, those triangles.
So this is sRGB in 3-D.
And it's interesting
because I mentioned that our
eyes see more in the dark.
And you can see that
in that diagram,
the brighter the colors, the
fewer Us we can perceive.
So for the demo, I'm using a
tool called Affinity Photo.
And this is a picture
I took, same process.
I took it in Adobe RGB.
I was using [INAUDIBLE] files
from my camera, from my DSLR.
I used ProPhoto RGB to
do my work in Lightroom.
And I created this RGB
version of the picture.
And if we zoom in, pretty much
any good design tool somewhere
will show you the color
space of your image.
So here we know
it's an sRGB image.
I'm going to calibrate
display, looks fine.
And like I said, you can assign
a color space, often called
an ICC profile, or
you can convert.
So if you assign,
what you're saying is
keep the colors the way they
are, keep the same values.
I just want to move them
to a different color space.
So let's say we move to
the ProPhoto color space,
and now it looks like this.
This is exactly
what Android does.
This is not the right
way of doing it.
Sometimes that's what
you want because you
know what you're doing,
but very often it's
not going to be what you want.
So instead, what you want to
do is do convert ICC profile.
It's sometimes called match.
So we pick ProPhoto,
and when I click,
you'll see no difference.
And this is what we wanted.
But what happens is that every
single RGB value has changed.
It just looks the same, we
just have different values
stored inside the image.
And to give you an idea what
happens to your Android design,
so this is a screenshot
I took of my pixel
2016 running Android N. And on
Android we pretty much assume
that all the content is RGB.
So when I opened this
file in the tool,
I was warned that there
was no color space
and that the tool is in sRGB.
Now when you display the
screenshots on a [INAUDIBLE]
display, because we don't
manage color, what happens
on that pixel 2016 is this.
So I hope you can
see the difference.
If you look at the right
icons at the bottom,
you can see that everything
becomes more saturated.
So that's what you
designed, and that's
what you see on an actual phone.
All right, so when you don't
know where the color space is,
just assume it's sRGB.
It's the only
assumption you can make.
And this is why, for instance,
all my photos are sRGB,
because when I put
them online on the web,
I have no idea what display
you're going to use,
I have no idea what device
I don't know if your app is
going to be color managed
or not, and sRGB
is your safest bet.
It won't be always correct,
but it's your safest bet.
So when you use a design tool
and you have a color picker,
if there's no information
about the color space anywhere
in the tool, you are most
likely using either sRGB or what
we call native gamut, which
is whatever the screen can do.
For instance, this is
what Apple Keynote does.
When you pick a color,
you pick the color
directly for your display
and not another display.
If your application
is color managed,
and your document
has a color space,
you're picking a color
in that color space.
Some color pickers
are more advanced,
so this is for instance, on
Mac OS Sierra, if you click
that little gear
in the second tab,
you can choose the
color space you want
to use for the color picker.
Actually when I was
working on these slides,
I picked colors for
the slides and then I
was creating diagrams
into a different tool
and I tried to match
the colors and I
forgot that I had to change
the two sRGB in this picker,
so it took me five
minutes to understand
why my colors were different.
So even when you know about
color spaces and color
management, it can
sometimes be confusing.
Another tool you can use
on Mac OS for instance,
and other platforms
with similar tools,
is the digital color meter.
It's in the application
slash utilities folder.
It lets you pick any
color on the screen.
And using the drop-down, you
can choose the color space
you want for that color.
So you can look at the
color in the native gamut
of the display, or you can
use sRGB, or P3, or whatever.
On Android, if you have a
recent version of Android,
and if you have a pixel
device, for instance,
if you go to the
developer options,
you can turn on the sRGB mode.
So here, what we're going to
do is apply color correction.
We're going to apply color
management to the display
to make sure that all the colors
are interpreted and reproduced
as sRGB.
You might be surprised at first.
A lot of people complain that
the colors looked washed out.
They were actually
more accurate.
It's just a matter of habits.
All right, so now some code.
So on Android, what
you've been using so far
is what we call the
ColorInt, just an int,
it contains alpha,
red, green, and blue.
And the only
assumption we can make,
because we don't know what
color space you are using,
is that it's sRGB, so
it's pretty simple.
Now in O, we're introducing
a crazy new API.
We've had that color
class for 10 years
but only as static methods.
Now you can create instances
of the color class.
You can actually use color
the way it was meant to be.
So you just call value of,
you give your RGB values,
and that's going to give you
a sense of the color class
in sRGB.
Because note, I didn't
specify the color space,
so my assumption is it is sRGB.
You can also specify
the color space.
So here we also call value
of, we pass the alpha,
so the order is
RGBa, when it floats,
and then we say that
we want that color
to be in the Adobe RGB space.
What this allows us to
do is work with color
so we can convert them from
one color space to the other.
So I have this Adobe RGB
color, and if I call convert,
I can convert it to
display P3 for instance.
Someone's happy.
Something else we
are introducing.
So color ints are really
useful because they're
easy to manipulate, they're
small, they're easy to store.
And color objects, the
color class is very generic.
It can represent colors.
It uses a float [INAUDIBLE]
as a reference to color space,
so it can be a
pretty heavy object.
So now we have something
we call the color long.
It's the same idea
as the color int.
We use a primitive
type to store color.
But we also store the
color space for that color.
So it's similar to value of.
You just call pack instead,
and you get to long.
And here's the
format of the long.
So we have 16 bits
for the red channel,
16 bits for the green channel,
16 bits for the blue channel,
we have 10 bits for
the alpha channel,
and then we have six
bits that identify one
of the built-in color spaces.
And those 16-bit
values, they use
something called half floats.
So they are floats that use
only 16 bits instead of 32 bits.
So there's a new API in O called
android.util.Half that lets
you manipulate half floats.
Anybody who does HDR or advanced
rendering in Open G or Vulkan
might find that API useful.
If you use the color
class, you don't have
to worry too much about it.
There's a ton of
utility methods on color
that will use the half
API on your behalf.
So we also have the
color space class.
It's well documented.
It's pretty easy to do.
You just call get,
and you can create
one of the common color
spaces that we provide.
You can create your own
color spaces if you want.
Two methods that are
interesting on color space.
There is white gamut.
It will tell you if it's a
whiter gamut than this RGB.
And get model, it will tell
you how many components
are in the color space, so RGB,
CMYK, Adobe, stuff like that.
If the model is
RGB, you can cast it
to color space
[? dot ?] RGB, that
gives you access to more APIs.
You can query the primaries.
You can query the white points.
You have access to the
transfer functions.
This is also very
well documented.
If you want to do conversions
between color spaces,
it's pretty simple.
You call connect, you
give us the source color
space and the
destination color space.
And the reason why where
you need to call correct
is that we need to make sure
that both color spaces use
the same white points.
So when the color spaces
have different white points,
we do a little bit
of math internally
to make them use the same
white point, effectively.
So then you can call
the transfer method,
you can give us RGB
values, and we're
going to give you back
the corrected RGB values.
You can also change the
white point of a color space.
So if you call
adapt, color space
dot adapt-- so
here for instance,
we do what I did for one of my
examples, my photo of the fish
that was very blue, we
took the sRGB color space
and then changed the white
point from something called d 65
to something called
d 50 that's bluer.
White points are usually
defined as a color temperature.
It's the perceived
color of a black body
when you heat it to
that temperature.
So here d50 is 5,000 degrees
Kelvin and it's blue,
And d65, which is a
very common white point
in color spaces
for our monitors,
it's 6,504 degrees Kelvin.
It's more yellow.
Bitmaps, we know, support color
spaces embedded in bitmap.
So they are called ICC profiles.
Until now, we would just ignore
it completely on Android.
So if you use bitmap factory
to decode the bitmap,
now you can call get
color space on the bitmap,
and we're going to
tell you what it is.
Most likely, for
most images you are
going to load, and presumably
for all your resources
that come inside your APK, the
answer is going to be sRGB.
So you can call a
color space that
is sRGB to check what
kind of color space it is.
And that's very important.
All the bitmaps on Android are
always in the RGB color model.
We might expand on
that in the future,
but we don't let you use L*a*b
or CMYK or xyz or any of that.
They are always RGB.
Right now, when you call get
color space on the bitmap,
can always cast it to
a color space at RGB.
It might not be
future proof, so just
make sure by checking
the color model.
You can do more interesting
things with bitmap factory.
So on bitmap factory.options, we
have this horribly named field
called inJustDecodeBounds.
It was originally
created to let you
query the dimensions of an
image without having to decode
all the pixels in the image.
So it's really quick.
It gives you an idea of how
big the image is going to be.
Over the years,
we've kind of abused
this field, so now
it's going to tell you
the configuration of the
bitmap, you know, is it RGB888,
is it RGB 5 6 5?
And now it also tells you
what the color space is.
So if you want to know the
color space of a bitmap ahead
of time, you have to
ask us to give you
just the [? balance, ?]
just the dimensions.
So you call your decode
method on bitmap factory,
you press your
options, and then we
have this field called out
color space that tells you
what is the color
space of the bitmap.
So if you want to make sure that
the map is in the right color
space before loading
it, you can do this.
And if it's not in
the right color space,
you can use this other API in
options called preferred color
space, where you
can tell us what
you want the color space of
the decoded bitmap to be.
So in this example,
for instance,
let's say we query the
color space of the bitmap.
We saw that it was Adobe RGB.
I don't want Adobe RGB.
I want sRGB.
So I can use in
preferred color space
to force the system to
convert it at load time.
Then you could just call decode.
We are also introducing in
Android O 16-bit bitmaps.
So they are bitmaps that
use 16 bits per channel.
And those bitmaps are always,
always in a color space called
linear extended
sRGB, and we're going
to take a look at what it is.
So when you have
a 16-bit bitmap,
don't try to convert
the color space.
We're not going to let
you, at least for now.
This is how you create
a wide gamut bitmap.
You just call create bitmap, you
specify the width, the height,
the configuration,
the Boolean tells us
whether there's
alpha in the bitmap,
and then you just give
us your color space.
So it's pretty simple.
Bitmap, as API, it lets
you read and write pixels
inside the bitmap.
So because get pixel and set
pixel are used color ints,
they have to use sRGB.
So when you call get pixel
on a bitmap that is not sRGB,
we're going to do a
conversion for you.
Same thing when
you call set pixel.
We expect this RGB, so you have
to do the conversion yourself.
Now if you use this other API
called copy pixels to buffer,
it gives you access to the
raw data of the bitmap.
So that data is going
to be the native color
space of the bitmap left
completely untouched.
You have to be a
little bit careful
because of that
new configuration
for 16-bit bitmaps.
So if you load the 16-bit png,
the data in that byte buffer
is going to be half
floats, it's not
going to be those color ints.
And that's where you
might want to take
a look at android.util.Half.
All right, so now
what happens when
you draw bitmaps on the screen?
Until now, what we're
doing is, we take a bitmap,
we assume it's sRGB, we
send it to the screen.
And if the screen
is not sRGB, too bad
the colors are going
to be completely wrong.
This is still what we do
by default on Android O.
Now, if we have a bitmap
that we know is not sRGB,
it has a color space
that's associated with it,
we're going to do an sRGB
conversion on your behalf
into the rendering pipeline.
It can be a little
bit expensive,
so you should avoid it
as much as you can if you
don't need non-sRGB bitmaps.
But at least the
colors are going
to be correct on the display.
Now if you render a bitmap
into another bitmap,
so if you create a bitmap,
you create a canvas
and then you call get
bitmap on that canvas,
we're going to convert from
whatever the source color
space is to whatever the
destination color space is.
So if you want to convert a
bitmap from one color space
to another, not at load time,
this is the way you do it.
You just create this destination
bitmap, you create the canvas,
and you just draw.
So pretty simple.
So we make all these
assumptions about sRGB,
but like I said earlier,
if you remember,
I said that all the displays
on our phones have wide gamuts,
they can show more
colors than sRGB.
Now the problem is is that
if we take your sRGB content
and we don't stretch it to the
entire gamut of the display
anymore, and we keep it
in that little triangle,
we have all those unused
colors that we're not
taking advantage of.
So in Android O, we're
adding this new API,
and it's super complicated.
It's just one
attribute that you add
to your manifest per activity.
You have to tell
us that you want
to render using
those extra colors,
you want the wide
color gamut mode.
The way it works is as follows,
if you are on a device that
does not support that mode--
not all devices will support
that mode, so if you are
on a device that does not
support that mode,
your window is going
to use the RGB 888 format.
That's what we've been
using for 10 years,
so there's nothing new there.
You have your sRGB content which
is drawn directly on screen.
If you have known this RGB
content, we convert it to sRGB
and we send
everything to screen.
Colors may be wrong,
but that's just
because the device does not
support the new wide color
gamut rendering.
On the device that does support
wide color gamut rendering,
we're going to make
a much larger window.
We're going to use
16-bit per channel,
so it's going to double the
size in memory of your window.
It's going to double
the needs and bandwidth,
so it is an expensive thing.
So if you don't really need
a wide color gamut rendering,
think twice before enabling it.
If we have sRGB content, we're
going to send it directly
to this display as well.
And if we have
non-sRGB content, we're
going to convert it to a color
space called extended sRGB.
What is extended sRGB?
In It's a kind of
weird color space,
it's a really big color space.
It's way bigger than the visible
spectrum, much, much bigger.
And some of the values are
negative and some of the values
are greater than 1.
They go all the way to 7.5.
And what's interesting
about that color
space is that all the
values between 0 and 1
match exactly the
sRGB color space.
So what it enables us to do
is, we can take your existing
content, all your sRGB content,
basically everything you
have in your app today, and
we can draw it directly.
We don't need to do any
conversion because it
is going to match sRGB.
So what we do is, we only
pay the cost of a conversion
when we're drawing
non-sRGB content.
The expense is that we
need 16-bit per channel,
because we need a lot
of precision and range
to be able to encode
this sRGB space,
but it's much better for you.
It's much simpler.
You just have one attribute
in your application.
Interestingly, because we
use 16-bit per channel,
because of extended
sRGB, we can or we
will be able to,
maybe in the future,
to render in HDR directly.
So we could have
HDR user interfaces.
We also have a new
resource qualifier
called the widecg
for wide color gamut.
So you can create layouts
or strings or [INAUDIBLE]
that are specific to a display
that supports the wide color
gamut rendering mode.
We also have a few
APIs that you can
use to query whether the
device supports wide gamut.
So if you have a
resources instance,
you can grab the configuration
and the configuration
will tell you if you have
a wide gamut display.
If you have a view, you
can call get display,
we give you a display
object, and you
can ask the display whether
or not it's wide color gamut.
So the main conclusion of
all this is don't panic.
I put a bunch of
hearts on the slide
to make you feel
better about all this.
I know it's complicated.
And no matter how
hard you try, and I
don't want to sound
disheartening,
but your colors are going to
be wrong somewhere for someone.
Like they're wrong
for me on that screen,
and I know a little
thing or two about
color spaces and
color management,
but you're not in
control of everything.
You're not in control
of the final display
and you're not in control
of all the software that
intervenes in the pipeline of
an application of rendering
colors.
So don't worry
too much about it.
Do your best.
Make sure that your designers
work on calibrated displays.
Make sure they work in sRGB.
Make sure the images
contain color spaces.
And you should be OK,
or just mostly OK.
So if you want to learn more
about transfer functions,
there's this talk I gave
last year with Chet.
So if you go to that url
and you go to minute 29,
that's when the color
part of the talk starts.
The first half is
about animations.
It's also super interesting.
You can also look at the
documentation for color space
at Rgb.
There's a lot of
details and information
about transfer functions
and what they mean for you.
If you want to learn
even more about colors,
I gave a talk at [INAUDIBLE]
US a couple of months ago.
I talked about
bending and dithering.
What is bending?
How can you fight it?
What do we do in the platform
to fight it on your behalf?
So if you're interested,
go at that url
and it starts at minute 36.
And I think that's it.
I only have one minute left so
I don't have time for questions,
but I'll be at the
Android sandbox
if you want to talk more about
color and color management.
Thank you.